The second gift included Somei Yoshino,...
...ten different varieties of double-flowered or manifold trees,...
...one variety with yellow blossoms, and some varieties with fragrance.
Two years later, after that rocky start,...
...a second, successful shipment of 3,020 trees,...
...selected from the banks of Tokyo's Arakawa River,...
...arrived in Washington in good health.
Most of the cherry trees were planted in the new Potomac Park,...
...including around the Tidal Basin.
This sightseer map,...
...published just two years after the first cherry blossom trees were planted,...
...features the Potomac Park Speedway,...
...which was envisioned as an ideal site for a "field of cherries" by early proponents.
The cherry trees along the Tidal Basin were well established by 1918...
...when this drawing was made.
Thanks to the painstaking work of the National Park Service,...
...about 125 trees remain from the original 1912 gift.
Fresh plantings over time have included 676 new trees between 1986 and 1988.
Four hundred more, propagated from the original 1912 trees,...
...were planted between 2002 and 2006.
Tokyo's gift of trees to Washington more than a century ago...
...remains a source of joy, delight, peaceful contemplation,...
...and beauty for Washingtonians and countless visitors to the nation's capital.
The annual blossoms have inspired events and traditions...
...that salute natural beauty and the cultivation of friendship...
...between the people of the United States and Japan.